welcome back to the David Pakman show
I'm fair and cousin sitting in for David
Pakman today
David's at a speaking engagement and
we're hoping we can have that clip up to
you in the very near future on
youtube.com slash mid-week politics one
of the more interesting things that's
happened I guess in the last 36 hours is
that suddenly the First Amendment the
freedom of the press itself in the
United States is facing an attack the
likes of which haven't seen in this
country since probably the earliest days
of this country what happened is that
Donald Trump was on Twitter he was angry
about the fact that the story came out
showing that he wanted ten times more
nuclear weapons at his disposal than we
currently have well he immediately
lashed out on Twitter said this was fake
news but more importantly you know of
him saying it's fake news is nothing new
at this point but the important part was
that he said maybe maybe we should start
revoking the licenses of these news
organizations that publish stuff like
this but that wasn't the end of it the
hope would actually was just the
beginning because Donald Trump
unfortunately once he's in a hole thinks
that the only way to get out of the hole
is to continue digging and that's
exactly what he did during a meeting
later in the day with Canadian Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau Trump had this
to say no I never discussed increasing
it I wanted in perfect shape that was
just fake news by NBC which gives a lot
of fake news lately
no I never discuss I think somebody said
I want ten times the nuclear weapons
that we have right now right now we have
so many nuclear weapons I want them in
perfect condition perfect shape that's
the only thing I've ever discussed
general mattis put out a statement or
his putting out a statement saying that
that was fake news that it was just
mentioned that way and it's frankly
disgusting the way the press is able to
write whatever they want to write and
people should look into it
it's disgusting if I'm interpreting
Donald Trump correctly here it's
disgusting that we have a first
amendment to the United States
Constitution how dare they have the
ability to write whatever they want to
write that's that's what the president
said I mean the guy whose main job is to
uphold and honor and protect the United
States Constitution just told us that
the First Amendment
maybe not such a good thing maybe we
shouldn't allow the press to just write
whatever they want to write right no no
that's not how it works Donald you can't
go out there and threaten the media and
then say you know maybe we should look
into it maybe somebody should look into
it
look the First Amendment allows for the
press to operate without interference
from the federal government the federal
government cannot tell you what to write
they cannot tell you how to write and if
you have a problem with it if they do
truly say something that is not true we
have laws that allow you to sue them and
hold them accountable for it and that's
one of the biggest things that gets
missed in a lot of this fake news talk
because what's interesting here is not
just the comment that he made in front
of Trudeau where he embarrassed the
United States once again in front of a
world leader it's the fact that whenever
he tweets these things out and you can
go look at his Twitter feed if you have
the time and look at the responses look
at those hardcore Trump stirs who say
yeah we need to take away their licenses
we need to stop the press we need to get
rid of these outlets they are right
there on board assuming of course that
these aren't just BOTS which a lot of
them you can clearly tell are the ones
who just respond 18 20 times with
nothing but a meme but there are
actually people out there in this
country a good number of them who
believe what the president has to say
Donald Trump's assault on the media is
an assault on the Constitution and
what's even more interesting
is that if he took the time to actually
read and learn something he would know
that yeah there's not just a single
blanket license given to a network like
NBC NBC is a content creator essentially
and they push that content out through
thousands of local stations all across
the country and it's those local
stations that actually hold the
broadcast license they're the ones who
get a license to be able to push out the
NBC content or CNN or whoever - viewers
all over their viewing area however if
enough people in that particular viewing
area petition the FCC they can get a
stations license revoked how do we know
because Richard Nixon tried the exact
same thing when he was president he was
angry at the Washington Post so he had
his acolytes take aim at a local station
owned by the Washington Post in
Jacksonville Florida did the same thing
with a station in Miami Florida tried to
get their license revoked because he was
unhappy with what they were saying about
him well Trump just like Nixon just
because they're saying things that you
don't like doesn't mean that they're
saying things that are not true and we
know that Donald Trump is no stranger to
lawsuits so if this were legitimately
fake news if they were defaming him or
labelling him he would sue them it's
what he does but he hasn't because he
doesn't have a case that's the the big
issue here and and let's not forget that
Donald Trump is not the only person out
there launching this new war against a
new war launching this war against the
press and the First Amendment a few
months ago the RNC admitted that one of
their tactics going into the 2018
midterm elections is going to be run
against the media they don't have Obama
anymore they don't have that bogeyman
they don't have the Hillary Clinton
boogeyman that they've been running
against so they've decided months ago
that their tactic is to run against the
media
and talk about how unfair the media is
and how horrible the media is to
conservative politicians it's all fake
news it's all awful revoke their
licenses it's a losing strategy do you
know why according to the latest round
of polling trust in media in this
country the people who say they have a
great deal or a good amount of trust in
the media is about 48% that is up 11
points from one year ago people in this
country who have a great deal of trust
for Donald Trump is at 48% that's down
several points from January of this year
so yeah right now they're about even but
it's going in the wrong direction for
the Republican Party people do not trust
the president trust and media is rising
why they may not get it right 100% of
the time I know a few times this year
they've jumped the gun on a few stories
that they've had to retract but Donald
Trump told 1318 lies and 263 days this
year I'd say the media's got a little
bit better track record than Donald
Trump at this not to mention the fact
media is on 24/7 they've got lots of
different people to come on Trump
eventually sleeps I assume I know it
seems like he's tweeting 24 hours a day
but you don't pick a fight with a
company that buys ink by the barrel and
yet that is exactly what Donald Trump
has done because he thinks it plays well
for the base he thinks it's gonna win
him more votes he thinks it's gonna
destroy trust in the media but by all
measurable indicators that tactic is not
working for him but he's not gonna give
it up as I said look guys in a hole he's
easy to keep digging
it's what he does it's all he knows how
to do he knows that if something bad
comes up he's got to keep moving got to
keep going gotta keep digging dig dig
and eventually he'll move on to
something else he's gonna he's gonna go
on and attack somebody else attack a
different industry and it'll go right
back to the media later on why
because he can't stand criticism it's
not necessarily that what they're
reporting about him is false in fact
it's quite the opposite it's that it's
true
Donald Trump has very thin skin one of
the you know most fragile dare I say
snowflake type presidents that we have
seen at least in my lifetime here he
doesn't like people talking bad about
him and why it goes against his
narcissistic personality disorder one of
the characteristics of that particular
mental disorder is the desire and the
need to be loved and he sees any kind of
criticism from the media as a direct
personal attack on him when healthcare
failed and the media talked about it
they were attacking Donald Trump when
they talked about the tenfold increase
in nuclear weapons that was an attack on
Donald Trump instead of just reporting
you know what what sources say or what's
actually happening in this world he gets
so upset because he feels like it
tarnishes his image it's gonna take away
from the love that the American public
allegedly or supposedly or maybe
possibly has for him he needs to worry
about real things there is a fake news
problem in this United States and you
know where it comes from
well according to recent analyses it
comes from places like Rush Limbaugh and
Breitbart and Fox News those are the
three largest purveyors of fake news
that have a national outlet in this
country according to a recent study a
you can find it on alternet today it's
very interesting that Donald Trump has
the audacity to go out there and rail
against fake news literally on the same
day that he gives an interview to Sean
Hannity of Fox News and the same day
that a report came out showing that
Donald Trump actually makes personal
phone calls to Sean Hannity usually
after his TV program airs there is a
very real fake news problem in this
country today and most of it is
generated from the right-wing
conservative media that Donald Trump
relies on
get his daily dose of feel-good trump is
great news
meanwhile the real outlets out there
occasionally reporting on real issues I
don't want to give them too much credit
they're not all that great they ignore
the big stories they ignore product
liability but to an extent they do a
fairly decent job in covering Donald
Trump hey listen I want to thank David
Pakman for letting me sit in today you
can follow me on Twitter at fair and
balanced Farr Oh in balanced you can get
more from Ring of Fire on our youtube
channel youtube.com slash D Ring of Fire
and coming up in today's bonus show
Donald Trump has a special trick to
avoid showing his double trend on camera
the KKK is trying to recruit high-school
students and a pharmacist in DC says
that members of Congress may actually be
suffering from Alzheimer's based on some
of the prescriptions that he's had to
fill in recent months stay tuned